In the last two videos, we
explored situations where
the aggregate demand curve
shifted to the right
and that caused inflation.
That's actually called
demand-pull inflation.
What I want to do in this video is study
a situation where the short-run aggregate
supply curve shifts to the
left and that causes inflation.
And that's called cost-push inflation.
So let's just start off
with our standard graph.
So this is aggregate prices.
This is real aggregate
productivity. Real GDP right here.
I'm going to focus
things on the short run.
Aggregate demand right over here.
That is our aggregate demand curve.
Aggregate supply in the short-run.
This is what we're going to focus
on, might look something like that.
So this is aggregate
supply in the short-run.
And this is our current level of prices.
And the reason why I draw aggregate supply
in the short-run as this curve that keeps
getting steeper and steeper.
Or if you think in algebraic terms, the
slope keeps getting larger and larger
as you go to the right, one
way to think about it is:
if the real GDP is down here and
maybe performing well below potential,
there is a lot of excess
capacity in the economy:
excess labor capacity,
excess factory capacity.
So if you want more productivity
out of that economy, people
aren't going to demand much more.
Prices won't have to go up more.
There's a lot of slack in the economy.
While as GDP gets higher and higher,
maybe even going beyond its potential,
starts to get overheated and
in order for people to get very
high levels of utilization,
essentially get more people to
enter the labor market, work
longer hours, work overtime,
the prices are going to
essentially have to go up.
So over here, for some increment in
GDP, prices don't have to go up so much.
So you have a lower slope than over here.
For that same increment in GDP,
prices have to go up dramatically.
With that out of the way, let's
think about what would happen
if the aggregate supply curve
were to shift to the left.
We can also think about "Why
would it shift to the left?"
So let's just shift it to the left.
It might look something like that.
At any given point, I try
to shift it to the left.
You see a new equilibrium
price and equilibrium GDP.
This is the old equilibrium price
and the old equilibrium GDP.
This is the new equilibrium price
and the new equilibrium GDP.
You see, you definitely had inflation.
Price went up, but this is worse,
depending on how you view things.
But generally, this is worse
than demand-pull inflation.
Because at least with demand-pull
inflation, you had inflation happening,
but real GDP increased
more as things get overheated.
Prices went up, but your
GDP actually contracts.
This is a situation where
you might have heard the word
before: this is stagflation.
Inflation with stagnation.
So this is stagflation.
There's two very notable examples
of this in recent US history.
In 1973, you had the Arab oil embargo.
It was apparently due in
response to the US support of
Israel in the Yom Kippur War.
So you had the 1973 oil embargo.
In 1979, you have your revolution in Iran.
Iran was a major oil producer then.
It continues to be, but it
was particularly so in 1979.
So, during all the chaos, during
the revolution, Iran's oil
productivity dropped dramatically.
So you had an oil crisis.
The reason why oil crises would
shift the curve to the left...
In both of these situations, the
supply of oil drops dramatically.
So if the supply of oil, and this
is kind of a micro-phenomenon,
if the supply of something drops
dramatically, the price of that
thing is going to go up dramatically.
And in the 70's, oil was an even bigger
part of the economy than it is now.
You probably remember if
you were around in the 70's.
Very very large cars that
had very bad gas mileage.
Other uses of oil were also much
less efficient in the 1970s.
So it was a big input into the US economy.
If all of a sudden, a major input's
price becomes much more expensive,
you could view it as one of two ways:
For a given level of productivity,
suppliers will want to charge more.
If you want me to deliver to your
house, if you want me to run a truck,
so for a given level of productivity,
suppliers will charge more.
Or you could view that at a
given level of price, suppliers
will want to produce less.
So at a given price, say this
price over here, a supplier
will want to produce less.
Because they are not
getting as much real profit.
So you could view it
as a shift to the left.
Or you could even view it at
a given level of productivity,
if you want to produce at that level,
you're going to have to pay me more
so I can offset my price increases.
So you can also view it as a shift up.
Either one.
But we'll think of it as a
shift left in this context.
So you see, this does describe
what happened during these
two oil crises in the 1970's.
Because of this increase
in the price of oil,
at any given price, suppliers
were willing to supply less.
Aggregate short-run
supply shifts to the left.
You have the inflation, and
you also have the stagnation.
Real GDP goes down.